بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
الوجي
الخلاء
place
of the place and act of
yesterday we mentioned
عاذ
بسم الله اللهم اني اعوذ بك من الخبث
والخبائث
غفرانك
ويستحب ان يقدم قدم رجله اليسرى في الدخول
واليمنى في الخروج وذلك لكون التيامن فيما
هو شريف والتياسر فيما هو غير شريف وقد
ورد ما يدل عليه في الجمله والحديث وال
والكلام
للحافظ الشوكاني رحمه الله في السيل
الجرار
المتدفق على نزهه الازهار
اند الشوكاني رحمه الله هيش
‏I don't think of people
appreciate how this princile is and that
is the princile of
me to give
to the right over the left in anything
‏et soئل
كان يعجبه التيمن في ترجله
وتنعله
واغتساله
وفي شانه
هكذا قالت عائشه في البخاري عائشه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
precedence to the right over the in
brushing
in putting on his clothing in putting on
his shoes in bathing and in all of his
affairs
and ‏So based on this he go tells us
that
it is preferable that when a person
enters the area of relieving ones that
they enter with their left foot and what
they leave they leave with their right
foot. ‏So they step over that threshold
with their left in entering, their right
foot in leaving.
And that is due to the fact that giving
precedence the act of or the practice of
giving precedence to the right over
the left in all things honorable
is a general principle. ‏and
stting with the left and all things that
are less honorable less desirable right
such as the opposite of these things
taking the you with the left taking the
shoes you with the left right
when we look at the prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم
the
price of right and left is very
consistent
صلاه صلى الله عليه وسلم كان ينصب رجله
اليمنى ويفترش
اليسرى عليه الصلاه والسلام
تشهد
up would
underneath
‏And for this you find that even in the
act of
many of the if not most have
traditionally mentioned that a person
put his weight on his left as opposed
toing his weight or placing a person's
weight on his right
‏do have
that we do there is some weakness in
these chr
however the principle is enough ofidence
for that right the principle which is
giving precedence to the right over the
left and issues of beautification and
honor giving beginning with the left
before the right in anything that is
الشوكاني رحمه الله
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
عليه الصلاه والسلام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
التسليم
anything
‏and
overossold
this is the
person enters the begin with the right
when they
left when a person enters his home he
begins with the right when he leaves he
begin with the left when a person enters
the maret place they begin with the left
and they leave with the
‏toi
they
are entering from
they with the right across the why is
this why in isl do we have this price
well
the the main reason
تشريف اليمين والتفاؤل باخذ الكتاب
باليمين وكون الانسان من اصحاب اليمين هذا
اسمه تفاؤل
‏and hopeful
and pr
to
اصحاب اليمين ما اصحاب اليمين واصحاب
الشمال ما اصحاب الشمال والسابقون
السابقون اولئك المقربون
‏people
are
الله
tells us there
are to people and people
number
[Arabic recitation]
هو السلم في لغه العرب واللي احنا بنحكي
له في لغتنا الدرجات بيت الدرج
المعراج
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الاقصى
مربط البراق
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ركعه
تحيه المسجد جبريل عليه السلام
جبريل عليه
‏And when he ascended he met the
most
honorable of each heaven seven heavens
he the most honorable of each in those
seven heavens and in the first heaven he
Adam and Adam
had souls to his right and souls to his
left you and me and everybody
‏wouldب
صلى الله عليه وسلم
parading
of peopleell
‏will
[Silence]
ابن كثير تفسير سوره الواقعه
المقربون
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اصحاب اليمين اصحاب اليمين
التيم
‏are
جعلني الله واياكم من اصحاب اليمين نسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان
يفقهنا في ديننا وان يستعملنا ولا
يستبدلنا والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه